This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. There's this old story and it goes something like this. A visitor arrives at the pearly gates and asks St. Peter if he can meet the greatest general who ever lived, and St. Peter points out one of the people in heaven and says, there he is, the greatest general in the world, and the visitor is shocked and says, no way! That's not the greatest general. I mean, that guy isn't even a general. I knew him on earth, and he was a cobbler. I know, response St. Peter. But if he had been a general, he would have been the greatest of them all. It's a bit corny, sure, but the story raises some interesting questions. That's a general Avery Trouffman. How does a person discover their greatest
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马斯。有一个古老的故事，大概是这样的：一位访客来到天堂之门，问圣彼得他能否见见有史以来最伟大的将军。圣彼得指着天堂里的一个人说，那就是他，世界上最伟大的将军。访客感到震惊，说，不可能！那根本不是什么伟大的将军。我在地球上认识他，他只是个鞋匠。我知道，圣彼得回答道。但如果他当了将军，他一定会成为他们之中最伟大的一位。这听起来有点老套，确实，但这个故事引出了一些有趣的问题。那是艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）的将军。一个人如何发现自己最大的
creative potential, their best skills and talents and capabilities? You might be a brilliant novelist if you could find the time, or maybe if you had the training, you could have changed the course of modern dance or particle physics or, you know, been a great general. So what makes brilliant and creative people tick? And how did they get that way? Today there are thousands of self-help books
创造潜力、最出色的技能、天赋和能力？如果你能抽出时间，你可能是一位杰出的小说家；或者如果你受过训练，你本可以改变现代舞或粒子物理学的进程，或者，你知道，成为一位伟大的将军。那么，是什么让杰出且富有创造力的人与众不同？他们又是如何变成那样的？如今，有成千上万本自助书籍
and counselors and consultants and websites that promise to help you find your creative essence. They teach you the habits of successful, effective, and creative people. But this idea that you can study something as elusive as creativity and learn step-by-step how to be more creative, it was unthinkable back in the 1950s. Creativity has always had something magical about it, unexpected, it's surprising, and that's
以及咨询师、顾问和网站，承诺帮助你找到你的创造力本质。他们教你成功、高效且富有创造力的人所具备的习惯。但是，认为你可以研究像创造力这样难以捉摸的东西，并一步步学习如何变得更有创造力，这在20世纪50年代是不可想象的。创造力一直带有一种魔力，出人意料，令人惊奇，而这就是
why people thought that you couldn't study creativity. It was too nebulous and unconscious and not accessible to scientific inquiry. This is Ravenna Helson. My name is Ravenna Helson. I'm very old, 91. What else shall I say? Ravenna Helson is a very prominent personality psychologist and she got her start at an unusual department at UC Berkeley in 1949.
为什么人们认为你无法研究创造力。它太模糊、太无意识，且无法进行科学探究。这是拉文娜·赫尔森（Ravenna Helson）。我叫拉文娜·赫尔森。我年纪很大了，91岁。我还能说什么呢？拉文娜·赫尔森是一位非常杰出的人格心理学家，她于1949年在加州大学伯克利分校的一个不同寻常的系开始了她的职业生涯。
It was called the Institute of Personality Assessment and Research, also known as iPAR. And what iPAR was was an institute with procedures for studying personality in a fairly new, complicated way. And we thought we were working on something really unique and good for humanity. The scientists at iPAR attempted what many people thought was impossible. This was at a time when creativity was thought to be this kind of magical, inexplicable force,
它被称为人格评估与研究中心，也称为iPAR。iPAR是一个以相当新颖、复杂的方式研究人格的机构。我们当时认为我们正在从事一些对人类来说非常独特且有益的事情。iPAR的科学家们尝试了许多人认为不可能的事情。当时，创造力被认为是一种神奇的、无法解释的力量，
but I-PAR set out to capture it, to study it in a methodical, scientific way, and identify the specific personality traits that make certain people creative. Ipar invited a whole variety of creative people to come to Berkeley and be studied. All there's a fantasy for children. Women studying at Mills College. Research scientists. Women mathematicians.
但iPAR着手捕捉它，以一种有条理的、科学的方式研究它，并确定使某些人具有创造力的特定人格特质。iPAR邀请了各种各样的创造性人才来到伯克利接受研究。比如儿童幻想作家、米尔斯学院的研究生、研究科学家、女性数学家。
And writers, including some real heavy hitters, like Truman Capote and William Carlos Williams. But one of the biggest and most successful studies that Ipar conducted was with architects. It's always important with the architects' show, because they were the largest sample and clearest in some ways. Over the course of four weekends in 1958 and 1959,
还有作家，包括一些重量级人物，如杜鲁门·卡波特（Truman Capote）和威廉·卡洛斯·威廉斯（William Carlos Williams）。但iPAR进行的最大、最成功的项目之一是针对建筑师的研究。建筑师的展示总是很重要的，因为他们是样本量最大、在某些方面也最清晰的群体。在1958年和1959年的四个周末里，
I part brought together 40 of the most famous and important architects in the world, observe them, gave them tests, and asked them all kinds of questions, including some fairly ridiculous ones. Now for the next 45 minutes, we would like to discuss this notion that is what if men had developed the third arm? Where am I going to sign the festive text? That is an actual recording from the actual study.
iPAR召集了世界上40位最著名、最重要的建筑师，观察他们，给他们做测试，并问他们各种各样的问题，包括一些相当荒谬的问题。现在，在接下来的45分钟里，我们想讨论这样一个概念：如果人类进化出了第三只手臂会怎样？我在哪里签署节日文本？这是来自实际研究的真实录音。
I part got really famous architects like Richard Neutra, IMPAY, Louis Con, all the big names of modern architecture. And I love that at one point they were asked to discuss where a third arm should go on the human body. I would suggest that the most effective place where if it came right out of the top of your head, I'd disagree with that. go on the human body. I part scientists observed the architects as they filled out questionnaires, made mosaics out of colored tiles, and discussed hypothetical problems together, and what they learned
iPAR找来了像理查德·诺伊特拉（Richard Neutra）、贝聿铭（I.M. Pei）、路易斯·康（Louis Kahn）这样真正著名的建筑师，都是现代建筑界的大人物。我喜欢他们当时被要求讨论第三只手臂应该长在人体什么位置这一点。我会建议最有效的位置是直接从头顶长出来，我不同意这一点。长在人体上。iPAR的科学家们观察建筑师们填写问卷、用彩色瓷砖制作马赛克，并一起讨论假设性问题，而他们所学到的
helped transform the way people think about creativity today. It all started with one of the first personality psychologists, the man who founded Ipar and led the charge on the architect's study. His name was Donald McKinnon. McKinnon liked to start his speeches with that story about the visitor to heaven in St. Peter, which makes sense. McKinnon himself had a vested interest in finding the secret, great general hiding within the Cobbler,
帮助改变了今天人们对创造力的看法。这一切始于最早的人格心理学家之一，也就是创立iPAR并领导建筑师研究的人。他的名字叫唐纳德·麦金农（Donald McKinnon）。麦金农喜欢用那个关于访客去天堂见圣彼得的故事来开始他的演讲，这很有道理。麦金农本人对寻找隐藏在鞋匠体内的伟大将军的秘密有着既得利益，
because during World War II, he had served in the office of strategic services, which was the precursor to the CIA. McKinnon's job was to assess the personalities of American troops to see which of them could perform well in combat. When the war was over, he joined the faculty at Berkeley and founded Ipar in 1949 to continue his personality research. But in the mid-50s, Ipar switched from studying combat readiness and efficiency to creativity.
因为在二战期间，他曾在战略情报局（OSS）服役，那是中央情报局（CIA）的前身。麦金农的工作是评估美国士兵的人格，看看他们中谁能在战斗中表现出色。战争结束后，他加入了伯克利教职，并于1949年创立了iPAR，以继续他的人格研究。但在50年代中期，iPAR将研究重点从战斗准备和效率转向了创造力。
In large part because of Sputnik. The Soviets launched the Sputnik and that gave a huge priority to the study. How can we make our folks, the Americans, more creative so that we can be the Russians? The space race was part of why I par embarked on this mission. They wanted to study the personalities of particularly creative people. So they categorized a group of analytic creatives, like scientists and mathematicians, and a second group of artistic creatives,
这在很大程度上是因为斯普特尼克号（Sputnik）。苏联发射了斯普特尼克号，这使得这项研究变得极其重要。我们怎样才能让我们的国民，也就是美国人，更有创造力，从而战胜俄国人？太空竞赛是iPAR开始这项使命的部分原因。他们想研究特别有创造力的人的人格。因此，他们将一群分析型创造者（如科学家和数学家）归为一类，将第二组艺术型创造者（
like painters and writers. But then there was this hybrid where it was neither one nor the other, but it was both, and they put architects in that group. This is Pierre Luigi Serrino, an architect himself and author of the Creative Architect inside the great mid-century personality study, a book that chronicles iPars Architects study, because they thought architects were a perfect mix of mathematician and artist. Architects were also interesting study subjects because understanding their creative habits could
如画家和作家）归为另一类。但后来出现了这种混合型，它既不是前者也不是后者，而是两者兼有，他们把建筑师归入了这一组。这是皮埃尔·路易吉·塞里诺（Pier Luigi Serraino），他本人也是一位建筑师，著有《创造性建筑师：世纪中期伟大的人格研究内幕》一书，该书记录了iPAR的建筑师研究，因为他们认为建筑师是数学家和艺术家的完美结合。建筑师也是有趣的研究对象，因为了解他们的创造性习惯可以
potentially apply to a lot of different kinds of people. Successful architects have to master numerous roles. They have to be businessmen, artists, engineers, lawyers, philosophers, psychologists, and educators, all rolled into one. I par wanted a huge test sample of architects from small firms and large. Some were sent surveys and participated from a distance, but an elite group was selected to come to Berkeley for in-person testing. That was the first step to identify really architect. Everybody would come up with some names, then they would rate them.
潜在地适用于许多不同类型的人。成功的建筑师必须掌握多种角色。他们必须是商人、艺术家、工程师、律师、哲学家、教育家和心理学家，集多种身份于一身。iPAR想要一个来自小型和大型事务所的庞大建筑师测试样本。一些人被寄送了调查问卷并远程参与，但精英群体被选中来到伯克利进行面对面测试。这是识别真正建筑师的第一步。每个人都会提出一些名字，然后他们会进行评级。
Ipar rallied a selection of architectural magazine editors and museum curators and professors to help select the most creative architects alive and working in the United States. So they come up with a chart and out of that, they say, okay, this is the letters of invitation. So some folks never return. I frankly, I never answered. But they actually did convince 40 of the architects on their list to come down on four separate weekends. And they warned them, this was not going to be easy. This is the grueling, you know, in fairness, McCain said, this is not going to be a relaxing weekend.
iPAR召集了一批建筑杂志编辑、博物馆馆长和教授，帮助挑选美国在世的最具创造力的建筑师。所以他们列出了一张表，然后说，好吧，这些是邀请函。有些人从未回复。坦白说，我从未回复。但他们确实说服了名单上的40位建筑师在四个不同的周末前来。他们警告他们，这并不容易。这是非常折磨人的，你知道，公平地说，麦金农说，这不会是一个轻松的周末。
The tests began pretty much right away. As soon as the architects arrived at the fraternity house that I-PAR had borrowed for the study, they had just 15 minutes of introduction before they took their first test. It was constant over the course of the weekend. The architects would be asked to make mosaics to assess their aesthetic sensibilities, go into in-depth interviews about their childhoods, and even see if they could be hypnotized. And during the downtime, they were still being observed by researchers with clipboard. Even cocktails and dinners, it's a time of study.
测试几乎立刻就开始了。建筑师们一到达iPAR为研究借用的兄弟会会所，在进行第一次测试前只有15分钟的介绍时间。整个周末测试都在持续进行。建筑师们被要求制作马赛克以评估他们的审美敏感度，进行关于童年的深入访谈，甚至看看他们是否能被催眠。在休息时间，他们仍然被拿着剪贴板的研究人员观察。即使是鸡尾酒会和晚餐时间，也是研究的一部分。
It's a very, very tight schedule. But my favorite test that the architects did was one iParr called the ethics problem. The ethics problem? Group one. I like it because it deals with a question that comes up all the time for architects and for creative people of all kinds, actually. It's about whether a creative person should be willing to sacrifice parts of their vision to please a client.
这是一个非常、非常紧凑的时间表。但我最喜欢的建筑师们做的测试是iPAR称之为“伦理问题”的测试。伦理问题？第一组。我喜欢它，因为它处理了一个建筑师和各种创造性人才经常遇到的问题。它关于一个有创造力的人是否应该愿意牺牲部分愿景来取悦客户。
And it's one of the tests I parted where they actually recorded the architects having this discussion. In the course of that, you realize who's self-absorbed, who is more collegial. Architects group number four on April 25th, 1959, we're going to focus on three characters, and to keep them all straight, we've got a musical cue for each one. The first and foremost is architect Ero Sarnin. He designed the St. Louis Arch, the Delas Airport, these dynamic, soaring structures that blend sculpture and architecture.
这是iPAR进行的测试之一，他们实际上录下了建筑师们进行这场讨论的过程。在讨论过程中，你会意识到谁是自我沉溺的，谁更具协作精神。建筑师第四组，1959年4月25日，我们将重点关注三个角色，为了理清他们，我们为每个人准备了一个音乐提示。首先也是最重要的是建筑师埃罗·萨里宁（Eero Saarinen）。他设计了圣路易斯拱门、杜勒斯机场，这些充满活力、高耸入云的结构融合了雕塑和建筑。
He is iconic today and was a superstar then. It was a huge deal that he participated in the study. The second character we're going to talk about in this group is Philip Johnson. The minimalist architect responsible for Lincoln Center and the glass house. His work is very square, very tidy. Actually, the selection committee described Philip Johnson as Interesting in the perfection of certain limited aims, very discipline in all of his work, completely disregards human beings.
他今天已是标志性人物，当时也是超级明星。他参与这项研究是一件大事。我们要谈论的这一组中的第二个角色是菲利普·约翰逊（Philip Johnson）。负责林肯中心和玻璃屋的极简主义建筑师。他的作品非常方正、非常整洁。事实上，评选委员会将菲利普·约翰逊描述为：对某些有限目标的完美追求感兴趣，工作非常自律，完全无视人类。
And the third character who we'll focus on was a promising, up-and-coming architect named Victor Lundy. At 36 years old, he was the youngest and least established in the group, with a very small but very impressive portfolio. Okay, so the virtuoso, Eros Arnin, the perfectionist, Philip Johnson, and the young upstart, Victor Lundey.
我们要关注的第三个角色是一位前途无量、崭露头角的建筑师，名叫维克多·伦迪（Victor Lundy）。36岁的他是组里最年轻、资历最浅的，但作品集虽小却非常令人印象深刻。好吧，那么，大师埃罗·萨里宁，完美主义者菲利普·约翰逊，以及年轻的后起之秀维克多·伦迪。
Along with two other architects, were served cocktails and given a hypothetical situation concerning a hypothetical architect named Mr. Brown. Mr. Brown is faced with a difficult decision. He has just finished the preliminary drawings for a very challenging and important structure. His client has told him that he likes Mr. Brown's proposal very much, and will accept it if he will change one fairly important aspect of the design. Basically, the client would like the design altered in a specific way and says he will have to reject Mr. Brown's proposal if the change isn't made.
他们和其他两位建筑师一起喝着鸡尾酒，被给出了一个关于一位名叫布朗先生的假设建筑师的假设情境。布朗先生面临一个艰难的决定。他刚刚完成了为一个极具挑战性和重要性的结构所做的初步图纸。他的客户告诉他，他非常喜欢布朗先生的方案，如果他能改变设计中一个相当重要的方面，他就会接受。基本上，客户希望设计以特定的方式进行修改，并表示如果不做改变，他将不得不拒绝布朗先生的方案。
Brown really hates this alteration, but this commission is highly prized and prominent, and of course, Brown wants the client to be happy with the building, and he has to support himself in his practice. As he's weighing these factors, the phone rings and the client asks for his answer. If you were Brown, what would you do? The architects then had to decide. Should Brown accept the change or ditch the project? Now we'd like you to discuss the issue candidly among yourselves and reach a direct conclusion at the end of 35th anniversary.
布朗真的很讨厌这种改动，但这个委托非常珍贵且显眼，当然，布朗希望客户对建筑感到满意，而且他必须维持自己的生计和事务所。当他权衡这些因素时，电话响了，客户要求他给出答复。如果你是布朗，你会怎么做？建筑师们随后必须做出决定。布朗应该接受改变还是放弃这个项目？现在我们希望你们坦诚地讨论这个问题，并在35周年纪念结束时得出一个直接的结论。
So I mean, we have to agree. This archival audio has never been heard in any public way before, like maybe only 10 people have heard it. So just sit back for a second and listen to the architects and the ice clinking in their glasses. So Cerenin, the visionary, starts the discussion. I think John should have anticipated that John should have had some alternatives.
所以我的意思是，我们必须达成一致。这段档案音频以前从未在任何公共场合被听到过，可能只有10个人听过。所以请坐下来，听听建筑师们的声音和杯子里冰块碰撞的声音。那么，富有远见的萨里宁开始了讨论。我认为约翰应该预见到这一点，约翰应该准备一些替代方案。
And Sarenin says that since Brown doesn't have any other solutions prepared, he should walk away. He has to be willing to drop the job at this time, or else he has no future. It doesn't happen that way in architecture. That's Philip, disregard human beings, Johnson butting in. It's a problem that's contrary to experience. It sounds very much like you've been reading Iron Rand. It sounds like you've been reading Iron Rand. Johnson is referencing the book The Fountainhead,
萨里宁说，既然布朗没有准备其他解决方案，他就应该离开。他必须愿意在此时放弃这份工作，否则他就没有未来。建筑界不是那样运作的。那是菲利普，“无视人类”的约翰逊插话道。这是一个违背经验的问题。听起来你一直在读安·兰德（Ayn Rand）的书。听起来你一直在读安·兰德的书。约翰逊指的是《源泉》（The Fountainhead）这本书，
where the main character is a fiercely independent architect who blows up his own building rather than compromise with a client. Make no mistake, Johnson would also refuse the client's changes. But he just thinks this whole scenario is absurd. No good architect would let this happen with a client. Now, I answered there that I would immediately refuse it because I was a that stupid and architect, and had that stupid client that would let this particular occurrence,
书中的主角是一位极其独立的建筑师，他宁愿炸掉自己的建筑也不愿向客户妥协。别误会，约翰逊也会拒绝客户的修改。但他只是觉得整个场景很荒谬。没有好的建筑师会让这种情况发生在客户身上。现在，我回答说我会立即拒绝它，因为我是一个愚蠢的建筑师，有一个愚蠢的客户，才会让这种特殊的情况发生，
and I never heard of it happening of other architects, either. Actually, Sarenin has been challenged by a client on a recent commission, and he is threatening to quit. Just Monday, I have to get to them and I expect me to quit. You expect to win by a thread of quitting. I say that the only power an architect has against the plan is the power of resigning. It can only resign once if it is the case is hopeless. Would you say that the case is hopeless as intended in the problem?
而且我从未听说过其他建筑师发生过这种情况。事实上，萨里宁最近在委托项目中受到了客户的挑战，他正威胁要辞职。就在周一，我必须去找他们，他们期望我辞职。你期望通过辞职来获胜。我说建筑师对抗计划的唯一权力就是辞职的权力。如果情况绝望，只能辞职一次。你会说问题中预期的那种情况是绝望的吗？
That's Victor Lundy, the young gun, piping up. I confess that I have to admit the possibility of of learning something from the client. Maybe there's something in what the client is leading to that will result in a better thing. If a work of architecture is really, really good, well then the owner will see it. And um... I just say yes. Well, you're young. Well, no. I'm young, but I've seen some old things.
那是维克多·伦迪，那个年轻人，插话道。我承认我必须承认从客户那里学到东西的可能性。也许客户所引导的方向中有些东西会导致更好的结果。如果一个建筑作品真的、真的很好，那么业主会看到的。而且……我只是说“是”。嗯，你还年轻。嗯，不。我年轻，但我见过一些老东西。
There's snobbery in some of this. If you could have been now, the design can only get worse and worse for your reputation. Because once you're represented by a building you don't believe in, what is the future of living? At the end of 35 minutes, the group concluded that Mr. Brown should reject the client's changes and walk away from the project. This was the conclusion that all of the different architect groups ultimately came to. Having this option is part of the luxury of being a very famous architect, of course. I hope in all of this that Mr. Brown was right. I think he was.
这其中有一些势利。如果你现在妥协了，设计只会对你的声誉越来越不利。因为一旦你被一个你不相信的建筑所代表，生活的未来是什么？35分钟结束时，小组得出结论，布朗先生应该拒绝客户的修改并放弃该项目。这是所有不同的建筑师小组最终得出的结论。当然，拥有这种选择权是作为一位非常著名的建筑师的奢侈的一部分。我希望这一切中布朗先生是对的。我想他是对的。
Ha ha ha! Maybe the client was right. After three grueling days of tests, after all the architects went back to their respective practices all over the country, the study still wasn't quite over. The architects were mailed surveys and questionnaires and they were asked to rank each other. Some architects refused to rank themselves and their peers. Others jumped right in.
哈哈！也许客户是对的。经过三天艰苦的测试，在所有建筑师回到全国各地的各自事务所后，研究仍然没有完全结束。建筑师们收到了邮寄的调查问卷，并被要求互相排名。一些建筑师拒绝给自己和同行排名。其他人则直接参与了。
Philip Johnson raided himself number one. As surprisingly, but Sarah and Enraged Johnson number two, after himself, consider number one. But the fact that people put themselves number one, it also talks about the conception of themselves clearly. And the architects' conceptions of themselves matched with the findings from a lot of the other studies that I-PAR had done over the years. The researchers began to notice certain patterns
菲利普·约翰逊把自己排在第一位。令人惊讶的是，萨里宁把约翰逊排在第二位，仅次于他自己，认为自己是第一。但人们把自己排在第一位的事实，也清楚地说明了他们对自己的认知。建筑师们对自己的认知与iPAR多年来所做的许多其他研究的结果相吻合。研究人员开始注意到某些模式
across creatives of all professions and all genders. We kept finding that we got the same characteristics associated with the people who were rated highest, whether they were chemists or artists or in other fields. It turns out all different kinds of creative people met similar descriptions. It has an interesting and arresting personality. It is non-conforming and has high aspirations for self. Also, creatives preferred complexity and ambiguity over simplicity and order. Creatives had the capacity to make unexpected connections and see patterns in daily life.
跨越了所有职业和所有性别。我们不断发现，无论他们是化学家、艺术家还是其他领域的专业人士，评分最高的人都具有相同的特征。事实证明，各种各样的创造性人才都符合类似的描述。它具有一种有趣且引人注目的个性。它是不墨守成规的，并且对自己有很高的抱负。此外，创造者更喜欢复杂性和模糊性，而不是简单和秩序。创造者有能力在日常生活中建立意想不到的联系并发现模式。
But creative people didn't necessarily have to have high IQs. Intelligence isn't as important to creativity as people had thought it was. And so I guess that's another thing we found. Average intelligence will do. And it's not as if this is directly related to intelligence, but the school grade point average for the architects was a solid B-. So I par found that creative people tend to be non-conforming, interesting, interested, independent, courageous, and self-centered.
但有创造力的人不一定非要有高智商。智力对创造力的重要性并不像人们想象的那样。所以我想这是我们发现的另一件事。平均智力就足够了。这并不是说它与智力直接相关，但建筑师的学校平均绩点是一个扎实的B-。所以iPAR发现，有创造力的人往往是不墨守成规的、有趣的、感兴趣的、独立的、勇敢的和以自我为中心的。
They tend to be. They don't have to be. You have certain traits and they come up over and over again and that's the creative personality, but it doesn't mean that they're going to be exactly the same. I feel like I kind of could have guessed all those, right? I think it's a lot easier to say, oh, we should know that all along after we've found it. This idea of the creative personality was remarkable at the time. I-Pars findings were lauded and spread.
他们往往是这样。他们不一定非要是这样。你拥有某些特质，它们会反复出现，这就是创造性人格，但这并不意味着他们会完全一样。我觉得我好像能猜到所有这些，对吧？我认为在发现之后说“哦，我们早就应该知道”要容易得多。这种创造性人格的概念在当时是了不起的。iPAR的研究结果受到了赞扬并广为传播。
But over the years, people began to think about personality differently. In the 70s, an argument was emerging that maybe personality wasn't something innate within us, and maybe personalities are the results of our environments and social expectations. Ipar and their mission were called into question. The 1970s was a terrible period for personality psychologists. Ooh, I should tell you about that. We had trouble getting grants, we had trouble getting papers accepted, and we had this horrible empty feeling ourselves.
但多年来，人们开始以不同的方式思考人格。在70年代，一种观点开始出现，认为人格可能不是我们内在固有的，人格可能是我们环境和社会期望的结果。iPAR及其使命受到了质疑。70年代对人格心理学家来说是一个可怕的时期。哦，我应该告诉你那件事。我们很难获得资助，很难让论文被接受，我们自己也有这种可怕的空虚感。
Ipar ended in 1992 and became what is now known as Ipser, the Institute of Personality and Social Research, which has expanded to focus a lot more on social and cultural context beyond analyzing individuals. But just because people aren't using iPAR's methods does not mean the study was all for not. iPAR did prove that creativity wasn't this mysterious, untouchable thing. The studies in iPAR are really sort of iconic in our field. This is Ocean Vartanian of the University of Toronto. His area of expertise is creativity and aesthetics research. If you take any kind of course on creativity either at the undergraduate or graduate level,
iPAR于1992年结束，变成了现在所知的IPSR，即人格与社会研究中心，它已经扩展到更多地关注个人分析之外的社会和文化背景。但仅仅因为人们不再使用iPAR的方法，并不意味着这项研究是徒劳的。iPAR确实证明了创造力不是那种神秘的、不可触碰的东西。iPAR的研究在我们领域确实是标志性的。这是多伦多大学的奥申·瓦塔尼安（Oshin Vartanian）。他的专业领域是创造力和美学研究。如果你在本科或研究生阶段修读任何关于创造力的课程，
the iPAR studies are always covered because they're considered to be the birthplace of the scientific study of creative personality. Today, researchers don't study creativity as a complete concept like iPAR tried to. Instead of studying it as a whole topic, they tend to break it up into pieces. The chunk that I'm particularly interested in is the neuroscience of creativity. So essentially, what happens in the brain when a person comes up with some kind of a creative idea? Ocean also studies architects and their creativity. But rather than using, say, hypothetical discussion questions, he will put them into an FMRI machine to look at blood flow in the brain. Because now there are novel methods whereby you can
iPAR的研究总是会被涵盖，因为它们被认为是创造性人格科学研究的发源地。今天，研究人员不像iPAR那样将创造力作为一个完整的概念来研究。他们倾向于将其拆解成碎片，而不是将其作为一个整体主题来研究。我特别感兴趣的部分是创造力的神经科学。所以本质上，当一个人想出某种创造性的想法时，大脑中发生了什么？奥申也研究建筑师及其创造力。但他不会使用假设性的讨论问题，而是会把他们放进功能性磁共振成像（fMRI）机器中，观察大脑中的血流。因为现在有了新的方法，你可以
actually have people design things in the FMRI scanner, as the person is really kind of coming up with a room design and the parts of the brain that are involved in that. But even though oceans techniques are really high tech, his research has its roots in these iPAR studies. He thinks that they were really significant. One of the major contributions that they made was to actually show that personality is a viable topic to study if you want to understand creativity. And if nothing else, the lasting legacy of these
实际上让人在fMRI扫描仪中设计东西，当人真正想出一个房间设计时，大脑中涉及的部分就会被观察到。但尽管奥申的技术非常高科技，他的研究根源于这些iPAR研究。他认为它们确实非常重要。他们做出的主要贡献之一是证明了如果你想了解创造力，人格是一个可行的研究课题。如果说还有什么的话，这些iPAR研究的持久遗产，
iPAR studies, maybe these recordings of these great architects as they discuss essential creative problems, like where on the body to put a third arm. Then it would be rather unsymmetrical. I don't think it would be as pleasant as if we could. It could be four arms. It's to me four arms is much more validity. I'm a Paul. I'd be talking about 40 back minutes for three arms.
也许是这些伟大建筑师讨论基本创造性问题时的录音，比如在身体的什么位置安装第三只手臂。那会相当不对称。我不认为它会像我们能做到的那样令人愉快。它可以是四只手臂。对我来说，四只手臂更有合理性。我感到震惊。我本来在谈论40分钟关于三只手臂的问题。
Yes. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Avery Truffleman With Katie Mangle, Kurt Colstead, Sam Green's band Delaney Hall, Shereef Yusef, and me Roman Moors. Special thanks this week to Raymond Neutra and Elizabeth Peale and Robert Levinson of Ipser, original music this week by Sean Rial of the band Little Teeth. The archival audio recordings are courtesy of Ipsir, UC Berkeley and Monichelli Press, the publisher of Pier Luigi's book, The Creative Architect, inside the great mid-century personality study.
是的。《99%隐形》本周由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼制作，凯蒂·曼格尔、库尔特·科尔斯特德、萨姆·格林斯潘、德莱尼·霍尔、谢里夫·优素福和我罗曼·马斯共同参与。本周特别感谢雷蒙德·诺伊特拉、伊丽莎白·皮尔和IPSR的罗伯特·莱文森，本周原创音乐由Little Teeth乐队的肖恩·里亚尔创作。档案音频录音由IPSR、加州大学伯克利分校和Monichelli出版社提供，该出版社是皮埃尔·路易吉的书《创造性建筑师：世纪中期伟大的人格研究内幕》的出版商。
The book goes into more depth about the architect's study and has images of all these interesting surveys and documents, including pictures of the mosaics the architects were asked to make. Victor Lundy, for example, used a whole rainbow of colors. Philip Johnson used only three colors, and Eros Arnan used only one color. You can see them for yourself at 99pi.org. We are a project of 91.7 K-A-L-W in San Francisco, and even though we can still feel their warm embrace, we are no longer produced on the offices of ArcSign, so you guys should stop coming by unannounced because
这本书更深入地探讨了建筑师研究，并包含了所有这些有趣的调查和文件的图片，包括建筑师被要求制作的马赛克的图片。例如，维克多·伦迪使用了整整一道彩虹的颜色。菲利普·约翰逊只用了三种颜色，而埃罗·萨里宁只用了一种颜色。你可以在99pi.org上亲自查看。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，尽管我们仍然能感受到他们的温暖拥抱，但我们不再在ArcSign的办公室制作节目，所以你们应该停止不请自来，因为
they got jobs to do and we're not there anyway. However, we do remain in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook, follow us all on Twitter and Instagram by the best way to explore the 99% invisible activity that shapes the design of our world Radio Tepia. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
他们有工作要做，而且我们也不在那里。不过，我们确实仍然留在加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰市中心。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞我们的节目，在Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，这是探索塑造我们世界设计的99%隐形活动的最佳方式。Radio Tepia。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。